Where we had left off, we had
expressed our line integral
over the boundary of our
surface in terms of dt,
in the dt domain.
We expressed what f dot dr
is going to be equal to.
What I'm going to
do in this video
is do a little bit of
algebraic manipulation,
and then we will actually
apply Green's theorem.
And whether or not we
have time in this video,
we'll then manipulate
that to show
that it's the exact same thing
that we saw in the earlier
part, where we evaluated
the surface integral.
And so let's do that.
So this integral right
over here is the same thing
as the integral from a to b.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to group the things that
are being multiplied by dx dt.
So if I group them and
then factor out a dx dt,
so if I take this part right
here and this part right
over here, I'm essentially
going to distribute
the R. Let me make it clear.
I'm going to distribute
the R. And so I'm
going to group that and
that right over there,
I will be left with-- and
I'll factor out the dx dt.
I will be left with P plus
R times the partial of z
with respect to x times dx dt.
And I'll do the same
thing for the dy dt's.
So that's that part
right over there.
And then the R is going
to get distributed
in this thing right over here.
So it's going to be plus
Q plus R-- the R is going
to get distributed-- times the
partial of z with respect to y.
And I'm going to
factor out a dy dt.
And then we can't
forget all of that
is going to be multiplied by dt.
Now, this right over
here is interesting,
because it's starting to
look very similar to what
we had up here, where we just
had our theoretical vector
field.
In fact, let me
copy and paste it.
So actually, I don't know if I'm
on the right a layer of my work
right over here.
So let me copy and paste.
No, that didn't work.
Let me try it one more time.
So if I try to copy,
I'll go a layer down.
I'm using an art
program for this.
Copy-- and then I think
this will work-- and paste.
There we go.
So this is a result
that we had before.
This is kind of a
template to look at.
But what is going on
over here if we just
look at this template?
We see that we're
in the t domain.
We're integrating over
t right over here.
But then we have these things.
We have some function that's
a function of x and y times dx
dt, and then some function,
the function of x and y times
dy dt, and we're integrating
with respect to dt.
Well, that's exactly what
we're doing right over here.
We can distribute
the dt, and we have
something that looks exactly
like this right over here,
where M is analogous to
this piece right over here.
Let me make it clear.
M, this piece right over
here, looks a lot like M
in our example right over here.
It's being multiplied by
dx dt, and then this dt,
which you can distribute, and
this piece right over here,
looks a lot like N.
And so, we can
say that, well, we
have something that
looks like this.
We can rewrite it
like this and go back
into the-- kind of
deparametrize it.
So this thing is going to
be equal to now the line
integral of C1.
We are in the xy plane.
We started with the curve C,
but now we're going to go to C1.
It's completely analogous.
These are only functions
of x's and y's.
Everything here is.
So now, this is going to be
the line integral over C1--
and I could even draw it as
that, if I like-- of M dx,
and that makes sense.
Because if you multiply dt times
dx dt, the dt's cancel out,
and you're just left with dx.
So M times dx, so let
me write it that way.
So it's going to be P plus
R times the partial of z
with respect to x dx plus n.
Let me scroll to the
right a little bit.
Plus n, which is Q plus
R times the partial
of z with respect to y dy.
And then this is
really interesting,
because this path that we
are now concerned with,
it's completely analogous.
I hope you don't think I'm
doing some voodoo here.
This statement is completely
analogous to this statement,
where M could be this
and N could be this.
And so, we can revert
it back to now the path
C1 that sits in the xy plane.
Not our original
boundary C, but now we're
just dealing with a
boundary in the xy plane.
So it reverts to this.
But what's powerful about
getting it to this point,
is we can now apply Green's
theorem to this to essentially
turn this into a double
integral over the region
that this path surrounds,
the original region
over this region R.
And when we change
how we manipulate that,
when we play around with it,
we're going to see that we get
the exact same result that we
got in earlier videos.
And I'll leave you
there, and I'll
see if I can do that
in the next video.